lo favolando hai fatto chiede aiuto c'è
qualcosa di strano perché è minuti sono
i castori oggi nuovissima e skiforum
belli ma oggi dobbiamo scappare da un
castello incantato fatato però dentro sé
una principessa super pasta tipo vedo
l'ora di vederlo e vedere come sarà così
schifo
poi se volete sapere che ci sono
esistiti in un mondo fantasy fantastico
e magico cliccate mi piace qui sotto è
l'ultima cifra nel vostro mi piace
corrisponde al vostro personaggio maggio
ma se volete scrivetelo nei commenti
e ora mettetevi comodi se non mi seguiva
in caratterizza g data seguirmi lo
merito story sorprende tipo carmelita
midollo
eccoci qua guardate quello il castello
in cui dovremo entrare era qualcosa tipo
stile supermario però magari con qualche
personaggio più pazzo degli ospiti di
oggi oggi versione fatina e qui c'è
qualcuno che si sta dipanando di 80 100
dire quattro realtà esistito aspetta
ho bisogno di qualcuno che mi aiuti a
sopravvivere queste avventure paurose
non posso riuscire a farlo morelli
ok seguisse allora va beh noi andiamo se
vuoi venire con noi viene quindi io sono
su questi funghetti però ci sono queste
la me qui sembra di mario davvero con
questi funghi tante volte si straccerà
vitali e occorrendo sono sfracellato
riuscita presto entra nel castello prima
che arrivi la tempesta altri e andiamo
ecco ci siamo dentro il castello ad ora
vorrebbero perché io a dorina della loro
troppo cupe ci sono delle armature male
benvenuti nella parte segreta del
castello tubere il cavaliere e troveremo
la stanza reale e la principessa e cromo
nella principale dice la mia stanza
reale che dobbiamo attraversare il
cavaliere dice che si svolgerà anche lui
mi fanno queste scopo e non prendere
fuoco nella ad ora tutte
quest'abitazione beni ad ora le cose
panta tv allora siamo il cavaliere qui
salta sulla volando è fatto battere un
armatura e cioè c'era qualcuno dentro
allora vediamo che si dice quando ci ha
mangiato ma sarà un po tifoso ma non
preoccuparti ce la puoi fare bene cosa
la lingua
tanti sono stragelato
ciao primo allenamento per vitale allora
cavaliere ha mangiato un acquario con
dell'area una svela anche lui non ha
applicato le cose come si fa a mangiare
un acquario intero questo non lo so caso
si vuole ossa lago la gola ok siamo
nella gola ma è caduto un dente ho
giocato mi i denti da qua o strade
qualche parola vediamo cosa c'è adesso
allora stai attenta e scivoloso e
attenta alle spade per che mordono le
spade che è morto ma dove dobbiamo
andare per salire qua allora vediamo
proviamo un po ha forse possiamo salire
e lasciamo che scivola disegnandole
sull'acqua affettato no vabbè adoro
queste sky burro c'ero quasi riuscito
però è dovevi dare il gruppo salviamo
[Applauso]
dove stiamo già allora si è scritto
benvenuti nel mio castello senti libero
di esplorarlo su cosa mangiare dal se
pensi sempre a quello di più anche la
musica ska p diaz 44 rossi cina forse
bisogna evitare questi profeti ua
un'altra spada una coppa
non vedo l'ora di affrontare la
principessa cattiva finale
no come questa bandierina si illumina
non so perché c'è scritto è passata la
mia ora di dormire
quindi è svegliati rapporto quindi
cerchiamo di scappare d'acqua dalle
presenze e mezzanotte vedi no ma sono un
buon basic e accaduto a dormire molto
carino ci sono dei ragni infatti io sono
caduto insieme ai ragni dove stiamo
capito o no ci siamo incastrati nella
cucina della strega vecchia non toccare
le di ragni che sono contento di
smentite cina però con i ragni non
voleva aiuto ok è stato bravo ora
dobbiamo trovare una chiave così
possiamo uscire da questa cucina abbiamo
una ricerca della chiave ad ore una
specie di labirinto questo che cos'è
questa è la chiave è come si prega è in
una mia chiave da no ok presa chiave
gigante luminosa che ora apriamo e
e truffa che cos'è che ci sono tante
frecce ha detto non cadere nella parte
verde ok quindi devo saltare sul bura
giustizia
bellissimo alla fine del video scrive
tesi che voto gli date da una designer e
daremo il nostro voto
ma questa secondo te io mi sembra la
caverna dei sette nani con i cristalli
immagine io sto volando il mito dell
aiuto
anch'io favoloso e terzo arriva sono
cadendo in un buco fatto in vita mia ho
chi sta arrivando è quello che quello
che ci sarà alla fine non ti piacerà ci
sono questi cavalieri che ci aspetta che
il piano piano ora senti qua 0 ok dopo
che siamo scappati da dell'escape room
super difficili tipo quella del
pagliaccio
oppure il castello malefico questa
sembra molto più facile per me sono
paura questi tal vi auguro che ora la
principessa o l'aiutante della
principessa non sapere chi sia dice sì
riuscita a passare i cavalieri ora
wright presentarle così possiamo non lo
dice interrompe vediamo che cosa c'è poi
abbiamo le scale o no ma dobbiamo
passare questa sorta di laser
spiaccicato
c'è scritto aiuto sarà un impostore tra
i cavalieri e mi sta nascondendo nella
torre del castello dopo l'oceano
dopo luce a salvare la principessa della
società abbia mostrato abbiamo
attaccarci a questo filo dobbiamo
cliccare il bottone dobbiamo aspettare
che passi ma perché io sono mia testa
attaccate nuova bellissimo per
panoramico allora devo saltare questo
brava possono renderlo si aspetta
c'è una barca che sta arrivando dal
tunnel assicurati di saltarci sopra per
salvarmi ok e dove sarà eccola qui ce ne
sono
[Musica]
non ci credo vita le cose di aspettarli
io lo aspetto sempre 9 ho fondato da
lapo non lo so che sta bene meglio così
aspettiamo la frutticoltura si sono
riuscito a salire ci possiamo sapere
tutto ma vi si buttano giù dalla nave
no vabbè momento fa fede
aiuto c'è qualcosa di strano perché devi
prendere il sole così sulla nave che
sono riuscite a salire e ora devo devo
fare qualcosa per fare in modo di non
cadere vitale ovviamente non c'è
riuscita insomma continuare a camminare
silvia ma se questi non cado donna di
malefico in questa barca però finora non
sono caduta disparità sulla prossima
nave fox ha affogato tre volte fatta
ecco la bandierina
ora aspettiamo vitale qua vede a
cominciare a comprendere la prossima
analoghe insomma se devi continuare a
camminare il continuo a credere
altrimenti gratis
va bene una nave con pirata vita la
palla andando tale sparrow siamo già
allenatore del castello per salvare la
principessa sarebbe non solo
contrattacco bravi che ci sia un drago
ok olio ti sei già buttato dire su eco
vitale si terrà nelle rane sfracello
questa secolare sia in tempi ratin
siamo finiti nelle segrete del castello
è quello il marito in una di queste
celle sono in una di queste celle vieni
prova a salvarmi
ok questo dobbiamo attento attento che
ci vuole fare a fette il cavaliere
qualità cella patente
delle cose fluorescenti ferita tetti
laser e anche qui questi così verdi sono
ancora viva non ci credo no no piano
piano un chiaro piano piano che salviamo
sappiamo c'è una chiave come parte per
salvare la principessa diana che andiamo
qui avrà e con lucchetto maxi lopez
ecco la scacchiera la principessa da
giudici solinas aperitivi 20p attenta mi
salvato sapevo che ce l'avresti faccia
ora andiamo giù nel paradiso per
festeggiare vediamo scegliere mettiamo
in piazza sediamo a cercare il
medaglione perché mi collezioniamo con
tutti per lui abbiamo fatto in venendo
c'è anche nessuna mano il suo letto
viaggia si facciamo camminando sul
banner che fanno la frenata è anche un
isoletta c'è una campagna nata forse la
sopra il medaglione la cascata no non è
possibile che sia lì la medaglione
perché è perché sarebbe cascato
scusate preti uno di quei cosi ti può
salire
allora da qua sopra posso vedere tutto
anche il castello che abbiamo appena
passato ma più di tutto
superata arriviamo da 1 a 10 e gli do un
otto e mezzo perché mi piaceva molto
l'ambientazione fantasy ix stato molto
divertente si era salvato la principessa
è vero poi che ha fatto gli date da 1 a
10 e ora 4 cliccare per vedere tutti
altri mercati su quella che preferite
buona visione